you're going to Australia I was just in
Australia we just shot a travel special
there in Australia and I had a blast and
I loved it what I'm curious about have
you been before haven't you been twice I
went for Travel Channel and I went I'm
what best days of my life
well my 40th birthday on Bondi Beach in
a speedo may be literally the happiest
I've ever been
215 pounds going in look at that my junk
I mean that is Australian Baywatch just
gorgeous
lopsided right sides I sleep on my right
side I think did you work wait did you
do wear a speedo when you went to
Australia not only did I not wear a
speedo I'm the most covered up guy
you'll ever see on the cover everything
when I'm I wear I wear like 1920s
bathing suits I and I have my arms
covered I wear everything he's on the
beach a lot of people go I thought
Katharine Hepburn was dead yeah I of
umbrellas I'm so horrified watch out
here comes powder yeah horrified by the
Sun travel channel they made me wear
sweat swim shirts because they said my
body is aggressive and so so the people
producing your TV show didn't want your
skin exposed at all nothing I don't even
think they wanted me on the show to be
honest with you and I love speedos I'm a
big speedo guy so like if I you love
speedos so much for these ears yeah I'm
serious
I don't think a lot of guys love wearing
a speedo Andy do you want to jump in
here you don't love wearing a speedo
I haven't worn one in years but I I did
wear them and it's a lot less fabric
flapping around that's for sure yeah who
likes to swim in shorts because it's the
Primo way to swim is naked yes and
speedos are one step away three naked
you are like a goddamn dolphin in the
water just
go to the beach in a speedo wear some
goggles to sport it up but I'm telling
you you are like a fricative goggles
goggles sport it out look if you put on
goggles everyone goes always an athlete
ok look if you jump to the speedo don't
see my body and know I'm not an athlete
no no no still see this and go oh ok I
hope he recovers because you'll still
don't feel be covered you wear a speedo
and a shirt and legging yeah yeah
I'm telling you speedos are the best try
it try it just try it you I put on a
speedo it's like my attitude changes I
want like a Tito's a speedo a little Sun
Hat cigar all things and then you get
the water in you're an athlete just
literally I'm not even joking I pitched
myself to speedo
when Ryan Lochte got in trouble for
ripping up the bathroom and all the you
know oh yeah yeah he lost his promote he
had a cold yeah we've all been there in
Brazil so so you yeah that's right he
lost his position he was a spokesperson
yeah your speedo and I saw an opening
and so you tried to get this is real
this is one big doctor is you tried to
get his promotional spot yup and be the
new spokesman for speedo
yes this is a real thing yes it's like
it's like listen listen when they say
okay okay hear me out
no one first of all is stopping you
you're on a talk show hold it hold it
give me a second to speak
okay
Jameson doesn't market to Irish people
they already drink Jameson yes they do
Vito's marketing to athletes they're
already wearing Speedos
I'm an untapped market yeah I figured
they're guys like me all over I'm
looking at them right now and we're not
wearing Speedos we could be potential
buyers so I said listen give me the
money you pay and lock me whatever it is
million dollars and then I'll wear
Speedos 24/7 every day for one full year
everywhere I go on airplanes I mean
speedos submission videos I literally
you did I heard this is true a hundred
percent a hundred percent I literally
thought it's genius marketing is like a
big guy speedos and that's that because
it goes wildfire I have no idea what
happened there we have we have you
brought one of your this is a real
submission clip that you don't know
which one you I have a bunch I did let's
let's take a look at one and see what
happens
[Applause]
[Music]
you use the car
I put solid money behind this [ __ ] is
the worst use of a drone you look
fantastic did you ever hear from speedo
have you ever heard from them call me go
stop please stop because they don't have
a sense of humor I started making
commercials that it looked like speedo
is sponsoring me and we need to stop
yeah they made you stop yeah yeah but I
mean still your speedo have you change
your mind have you thought speedo is
gonna go from cease-and-desist to how
much we must have you I just they never
heard me out I feel like a psycho boy
for ex-boyfriend they never heard me out
we're an untapped market our body's
Speedos me and you diving through the
water right sure you cut me out of
everybody I know but you're still in
kind of good shape me and him okay okay
okay ready I walk out first then Andy
comes out behind me and we're like hey
my name is Bert and this is Andy we're
the folks were in the speedo and then
you come out you go hold on in your
speedo you ready for this yeah it's it's
a the pixilated so it looks like it's a
pixelated print so it just looks like
you're naked and they're blocking it you
like why does we make it make you laugh
it's just you naked I like that
like it's just a picture of you naked
but it's a speedo get it yes I feel like
we're are you okay control you're out of
control of hey sure this is what happens
when we talk about speedos yeah a speedo
if you're out there this is the guy this
is the guy who can turn it around for
you don't be idiot
please get me a piece done done veal
- Siebert on his body shots world tour
go to Burt Burt Burt calm whoo head Burt
Burt calm the dog a dog yeah is that
true yeah sorry ed no